Speaker 1: So I want to start today with something
that gives me great pleasure. It's video of our
friend, Congressman Jamie Raskin, who appeared
on this program not long ago and who I think is
doing an excellent job, basically making a fool
out of Republican Congressman Thomas Massie,
because Massie sees conspiracies everywhere
now, in particular in this clip. It's all
about Ray Epps. Now, if you haven't heard about
Ray Epps, I'm going to tell you about him in a
moment. But it's important that, you know, before
we look at the clip, there are some on the right
who believe that an individual named
Ray Epps, who appeared in Washington,
D.C. on January 5th in some videos is either an
agent or an asset or an informant of the FBI who
essentially encouraged Trumpists to do what they
did on January 6th and that the entire thing was
staged slash encouraged by the FBI. There is
no evidence for this whatsoever. Republicans,
some are obsessed with it. And Jamie Raskin
in this clip rightly points out to Massey,
Why is everything a conspiracy to
you? And take a look at the first few
seconds alone are extremely informative.
Speaker 2: Mr. Epps was in front of the.
Speaker 3: January 6th committee and we were
told that a transcript of his interview would
be released. But it's never been released.
Speaker 1: And I wondered.
Speaker 4: Was he sworn none of the transcripts
have been released. So you don't need a conspiracy
theory about that. We haven't released any.
Speaker 1: Where you press. So this is such a
it's a it's just the beginning of this clip.
But it's so important. A lot of these right
wingers love to say, hey, but what about this?
This is suspicious. And oftentimes the this is
just the way things are done. And so in this case,
Massey says, you haven't released the transcript
from when we spoke to Ray Epps. And Jamie Raskin
says We've done a thousand interviews. We haven't
released any transcripts. There's nothing special
about Ray Epps. It's sort of like when Republicans
claim voter fraud and you say, Okay, well, what
is the basis for that claim? And they say, Well,
the pictures of every scanned ballot haven't been
released to us. That's never done in any state,
even states where the margin of victory is
massive. That's not that's not something
that's a red flag. Okay, let's continue.
Speaker 3: When he was interviewed,
that would give me.
Speaker 4: No, I was not. I was
not. We've done more than a thousand interviews.
You guys are trying to make this poor schmuck who
showed up to your protest into something a lot
bigger than he is. Okay? He's just trying to
survive and he's on your side. You don't have
many voters left. You might want to try to hang
on to them without demonizing and vilifying
your own people. Isn't that great? That's
the Donald Trump way. So everybody else down
the road. Unless you're going to get a pardon,
some people are still hanging around waiting for
their pardon. But most people have opened their
eyes about what he's done to our country, what
he's done to his family. Have you guys ever read
the book by Mary Trump about the way that Donald
Trump has absolutely destroyed their family?
Wrecked her father's life? They do it to family,
they do it to friends, they do it to their own
associates and employees. And now you guys are
doing it to this poor Ray Epps. Leave that guy
alone. Whoever he is.
Speaker 1:
So very nicely done by Jamie Raskin. And they love
to see conspiracies everywhere, even when there
are none. There's a really good FactCheck.org
article about the entire Ray Epps thing. The
quick take is Ray Epps was at the Capitol,
but there is no evidence he was an FBI plant.
There is evidence that Epps once held a leadership
role in the Oath Keepers, some of whose members
have been charged in the attack. Ray Epps is a
60 year old. He owns a wedding venue in Phenix,
Arizona. The FBI put a picture of him on a list
of people they were seeking information about.
And the conspiracy theories about Ray Epps
include he just doesn't really seem like a
random insurrectionist. He seems more like
law enforcement. The other circumstantial
claim that's made by some Trumpists is he was
on a list of people the FBI wanted to talk to
and suddenly he was off the list. Well, maybe
it's because the FBI found him and talked to
him. Everything is a conspiracy with these
people and they should be ridiculed the way
that Jamie Raskin did. I saw a funny comment on
Twitter that Thomas Massie really has melted from
office space survivor vibes. You know, the guy who
where is where is my stapler? But that's my that's
my favorite stapler. It is very accurate. There
is that exact vibe to Thomas Massie and Reps.
Raskin calls him a poor schmuck. Maybe I wouldn't
go that far, but he's certainly a right winger and
he was certainly in Washington, D.C. on January
5th, sixth. And he certainly is not an FBI plant.